bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler de cette théorie célèbre et
pourtant bien mystérieuse qu'on appelle
la théorie des cordes
la théorie des cordes vous le savez sans
doute c'est une théorie qui prétend
unifiée dans un seul cadre toute la
physique fondamentale ce qu'on appelle
prétentieusement une théorie du tout
alors si vous avez suivi mon épisode sur
stephen hawking vous savez que la
principale difficulté quand on essaie de
faire une théorie du tout c'est celle
d'unifier ensemble la mécanique
quantique et la relativité générale la
mécanique quantique c'est la théorie qui
permet de décrire la matière au niveau
microscopique
c'est à dire les atomes le noyau des
atomes et puis toute la physique des
particules
à côté de ça la relativité générale
c'est la théorie qui décrit plutôt le
monde de l'infiniment grand
c'est à dire le mouvement des galaxies
les trous noirs l'expansion de l'univers
et puis jusqu'à la théorie du big bang
quand on dit qu'on veut unifier ensemble
la mécanique quantique et la relativité
générale
ça laisse un peu sous-entendre que ces
deux théories se situerait sur le même
plan en fait ce sont deux théories dans
la nature est très différente
la relativité générale c'est une théorie
qui décrit une force la force de gravité
à la limite on pourrait la comparer à
des théories qui décrivent d'autres
forces comme par exemple la théorie de
coulon qui décrit la forces
électrostatiques entre de particules
chargées ou alors un petit peu plus
compliqué la théorie de maxwell qui
décrit la force électromagnétique la
mécanique quantique à côté de ça c'est
pas une théorie qui décrit une force
c'est plutôt un ensemble de principes
qui permettent de comprendre comment les
forces se comporte au niveau
microscopique
donc si par exemple vous avez une
théorie qui décrit une force et dont
vous savez qu'elle est correct au niveau
macroscopique ce que la mécanique
quantique vous dis c'est que il ya
toutes les chances que votre théorie ne
fonctionne pas au niveau microscopique
par contre avec annick pratique vous
donne une série de guides qui vont vous
permettre de fabriquer une version
quantique de votre théorie qui elle va
fonctionner au niveau microscopique
c'est ce qu'on appelle faire la
quantification d'une théorie
on peut prendre un exemple si vous
considérez la théorie de coulon donc qui
permet de décrire l'interaction
électrostatique vous pouvez utiliser
cette théorie pour décrire la manière
dont une charge négative par exemple va
tourner autour d'une charge positive
si vos deux charges sont au niveau
macroscopique ça va bien fonctionner par
contre si vous voulez utiliser cette
théorie pour décrire la manière dont un
électron tourne autour d'un proton au
niveau microscopique la théorie ne va
plus marcher mais la mécanique quantique
vous permet d'adapter cette théorie donc
en la quantifiant et en fabriquant ainsi
ce qui est en fait la théorie quantique
de l'atome d'hydrogène
on veut prendre un exemple plus
compliqué si vous considérez la force
électromagnétique donc c'est une force
un petit peu plus générale que juste
l'électrostatique au niveau
macroscopique
elle est décrite par la théorie de
maxwell et c'est cette théorie qui
permet notamment de comprendre comment
les ondes électromagnétiques se propage
par exemple les ondes lumineuses ou les
ondes radio au niveau microscopique
cette théorie va pas fonctionner mais si
vous lui appliquer les principes de la
mécanique quantique que vous la
quantifier vous tombez sur une théorie
qu'on appelle l'électrodynamique
quantique et qui permet de comprendre le
comportement de la lumière au niveau
microscopique et par exemple de montrer
que au niveau microscopique la lumière
est faite de photons cette théorie de
l'électrodynamique quantique elle a
notamment été beaucoup développée par un
certain richard feynman
et vous allez voir qu'on va reparler de
feynman dans un instant on joue comme ça
vous voyez que le problème d'unifier
ensemble mécanique quantique et
relativité générale c'est simplement le
problème d'arrivée à appliquer les
principes de la mécanique quantique à la
force de gravité décrite par la
relativité générale la théorie de la
relativité générale elle décrit bien la
force de gravité au niveau macroscopique
ce qu'on aimerait arriver à faire c'est
à quantifier cette théorie pour
fabriquer une théorie de la force de
gravité qui fonctionne au niveau
microscopique ce qu'on appelle
hypothétiquement une théorie de la
gravité quantique d'ailleurs souvent le
problème de la théorie du tout on
l'appelle simplement le problème de la
gravité quantique
le problème c'est qu appliquer les
principes de la mécanique quantique à
une théorie macroscopique
c'est pas du tout simple je vous ai
présenté ça comme c'était une sorte de
procédure automatique
en fait c'est plutôt une sorte de
recettes de cuisine un petit peu flou
qui nous dit comment il faudrait faire
mais c'est pas du tout immédiat et
l'autre difficulté c'est qu'il faut en
général utilisé des objets mathématiques
qui sont beaucoup plus compliquées que
les objets mathématiques qu'on avait au
départ
si vous connaissez un tout petit peu la
théorie quantique de l'atome d'hydrogène
vous savez que ça utilise des maths qui
sont quand même un chouïa plus compliqué
que la description de la force de coulon
en pratique c'est même tellement
compliqué d'appliquer les principes de
la mécanique quantique qu'on y arrive
quasiment jamais de manière exacte alors
dans le cas de l'atome d'hydrogène
on y arrive parce que c'est très simple
mais dès qu'on passe à quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus compliqué comme par
exemple le champ électromagnétique
on n'y arrive plus c'est d'ailleurs même
un problème de recherche en maths que de
trouver les bons objets qui permettent
de décrire de manière exacte certaine
théorie quantique des champs
il ya même un des prix du millénaire
vous savez les prix à un million de
dollars en mathématiques qui est
consacré à une question technique de la
théorie quantique des champs donc en
pratique les physiciens ont été obligés
de faire une simplification pour arriver
à appliquer les principes de la
mécanique quantique à des théories comme
l'électromagnétisme et ils ont été
obligés de faire ce qu'on appelle de la
quantification perturbe hâtives
l'idée de la quantification perturbe
hâtive c'est en gros de considérer que
toutes les situations auxquels on a
affaire ne sont que des petites
perturbations autour d'une situation
bien connue
on peut prendre une analogie c'est comme
si vous vouliez étudier les mouvements
l'océan et que vous disiez que vous
allez vous limiter simplement à l'étude
des petites vaguelettes à la surface
d'une au calme dans le cas du champ
électromagnétique ce principe de
perturbation est pas complètement
absurde puisque en général quand on a un
photon qui passe ou une onde lumineuse
les champs électriques et magnétiques
associés sont très petits donc on peut
considérer que ce sont des petites
perturbations
et si on applique le principe de la
quantification perturbe hâtive à
l'électromagnétisme on tombe donc sur
cette théorie qu'on appelle
l'électrodynamique quantique alors
l'électrodynamique quantique je vous le
dis elle a notamment été beaucoup
développée par richard feynman effet une
manne a mis au point un outil qui est au
coeur de toutes les méthodes
d'identification perturbé
c'est ce qu'on appelle les diagrammes de
feynman si vous ouvrez un livre de
physique des particules vous allez voir
que c'est truffé de petits dessins et
ses petits dessins donc les diagrammes
de feynman
ils sont là pour représenter des
interactions entre particules par
exemple sur le diagramme qu'on voit ici
on a un électron et un positron qui se
rencontrent kisan et ils ensemble pour
donner un photon et puis un petit peu
plus tard ce faute on se re désintègre
en un électron et un positron alors ces
petits dessins ils sont pas juste là
pour représenter ou illustrer des
phénomènes
c'est aussi des équations c'est à dire
que un physicien des particules est
capable de traduire ce dessin en
équation de mettre un nom dessus
et ce nombre il va représenter la
probabilité que l'événement qu'on a
dessiné se produise la quantification
perturbe hâtive ça marche extrêmement
bien puisque ça a permis de fabriquer
les versions quantique de trois des
quatre forces fondamentales
vous savez on dit souvent qu'il ya
quatre forces fondamentales la force
électromagnétique la force nucléaire
forte la force nucléaire faible et la
force de gravité donc décrite par la
relativité générale et ben la
quantification perturbe hâtives on a
réussi à l'appliquer aux trois premières
et en mettant ensemble ce qu'on a obtenu
on a formé le modèle standard de la
physique des particules le modèle
standard de la physique des particules
c'est la théorie qui décrit aujourd'hui
toute la physique des particules connues
c'est une théorie qui est extrêmement
bien confirmé expérimentalement avec
toutes les expériences qui ont été
faites dans les accélérateurs de
particules est d'ailleurs la dernière
pièce à l'édifice a été ajouté il ya pas
longtemps avec la découverte du boson de
higgs
évidemment quand on voit ça la première
chose qu'on se dit c'est si on veut
fabriquer la version quantique de la
relativité générale
on n'a qu'à appliquer la méthode qui a
fonctionné avec les autres forces on n'a
qu'à appliquer la quantification
perturbe hâtives et bien le problème
c'est que appliquer la quantification
perturbe hâtive à la relativité générale
ça ne marche pas
imaginons vous vouliez appliquer les
principes de la quantification perturbe
hâtive à la relativité générale vous
allez faire comme dans les autres
théories c'est à dire que vous allez
commencer à écrire les diagrammes de
feynman qui sont associés et je vous ai
dit ces diagrammes de feynman
il représente dénombré représentent des
probabilités que les événements se
produisent et le problème c'est que si
vous faites ça dans le cas de la
relativité générale les diagrammes de
feynman
ils valent toujours l'infini c'est à
dire que vous obtenez une théorie ou dès
que vous essayez de calcul est quelque
chose de physique avec la théorie vous
réponds l'infini donc utiliser les
principes de la quantification perturbe
hâtive pour la relativité générale ça ne
marche pas et ça c'est quelque chose de
très important à comprendre parce que
c'est le point de départ de toutes les
autres approches qui ont été développées
depuis pour essayer de fabriquer une
théorie de la gravité quantique et donc
qu'on fait les théoriciens des cordes
pour contourner ce problème
eh bien ils ont décidé de reprendre les
choses un petit peu à la base et de
faire l'hypothèse que l'univers n'est
pas fait de particules ponctuel mais
qu'il ait fait de petites cordes
alors qu'est ce que ça change quand vous
avez une particule qui se déplacent
elles tracent une ligne dans l'espace
alors que quand vous avez une corde il
faut s'imaginer un petit cercle
il va tracer un tube
et donc si vous reprenez la méthode de
quantification perturbe hâtives en
prenant en compte ce changement
les diagrammes de feynman au lieu d'être
des petites lignes qui se branchent
entre elles ça devient des petits tubes
qui se branchent entre eux alors au delà
du changement sur le dessin ce qui est
très important c'est que ça fait
disparaître les infinies qui
apparaissait autrement dans le calcul
c'est à dire que faire cette hypothèse
que le monde ait fait de petites cordes
ça résout le problème fondamental qui
était que la quantification perturbe
hâtive ne fonctionnait pas avec la
relativité générale
ça c'est la première bonne nouvelle
l'autre grande nouvelle c'est que dans
le modèle standard de la physique des
particules
vous avez besoin de supposer qu'il
existe plein de types de particules
différent des neutrinos des électrons
des quark en théorie des cordes
vous n'avez besoin que d'un seul type de
cordes alors pourquoi parce que une
corne
elle peut vibrer sur elle même un peu à
la manière d'une corde de guitare et
comme une corde de guitare elle peut
vibrer de différentes manières qu'on
appelle les différents modes et les
différents modes de vibration d'une
corde permettent de produire les
différents types de particules qu'on
trouve dans le modèle standard c'est à
dire que au lieu d'avoir à introduire
plein type de particule différents vous
utilisez seulement un seul type de
cordes
alors ça c'était pour les bonnes
nouvelles maintenant dans les mauvaises
nouvelles
il ya quand même un petit problème avec
la théorie des cordes ya ce qu'on
appelle une anomalie c'est quelque chose
qui rend la théorie inconsistante au
niveau quantique est le seul moyen de se
débarrasser de cette inconsistance c'est
de changer le nombre de dimensions de
l'espace temps alors suivant les
versions de la théorie des cordes
il faut utiliser soit 26 dimensions soit
dix dimensions
en fait la théorie d'ailleurs à 26
dimension on sait que pour d'autres
raisons il n'est pas correct donc toutes
les théories modernes des cordes impose
d'utiliser dimension donc dix dimensions
ça veut dire une dimension de temps et
neuf dimensions l'espace alors le
problème c'est que jusqu'ici des
dimensions des spasmes moi j'en connais
que 3 donc je vais bien qui en est neuf
mais il faut m'expliquer où sont les six
autres alors l'astuce qu'on trouvait les
théoriciens des cordes c'est à dire les
six dimensions supplémentaires
en fait on les voit pas parce qu'elles
sont très petites
et qu'elles sont repliées sur elles
mêmes alors pour comprendre ça on peut
considérer le cas d'un plan
alors prenez une feuille de papier
imaginer que la feuille de papier l
infini vous avez deux dimensions
les deux dimensions sont infinies
maintenant si au lieu de considérer une
feuille de papier vous considérez un
très long cylindre de papier vous voyez
qu'il ya toujours deux dimensions
sauf que cette fois vous avez une
dimension infinie et une dimension qui
est finie et elle est finie parce
qu'elle est repliée sur elle même
maintenant imaginez que vous regardez un
cylindre de très loin par exemple
regarder un fil de fer
bon bah ce cylindre il a toujours deux
dimensions
sauf que une des dimensions la dimension
qui est finie elle est tellement petit
qu'on la voit pas et donc on peut avoir
l'impression qu'il n'ya qu'une dimension
alors qu'en fait il y en a deux et c'est
ce principe là qui d'après les
théoriciens des cordes permet
d'expliquer que les six dimensions
supplémentaires de l'espace on les voit
pas c'est parce qu'elles sont cachées
elles sont de taille finie et très petit
pour comprendre comment on va décrire sa
mathématiquement on peut revenir sur le
cas du cylindre un cylindre
géométriquement on peut se le
représenter comme étant une droite et en
chaque point de ma droite je dessine un
petit cercle
mathématiquement on dit qu un cylindre
c'est une droite fois un cercle
l'avantagé de cette écriture c'est
qu'elle permet de mettre en évidence le
fait qu'il ya une dimension infinie et
une dimension fini alors avant de passer
au cas de la théorie des cordes je
voudrais juste qu'on regarde un cas un
petit peu plus compliqué imaginons que
je veuille fabriquer un espace à quatre
dimensions de dimension infinie et deux
dimensions fini bon bah pour fermer deux
dimensions est fini je vais prendre un
plan
et puis en chaque point de mon plan je
vais poser un petit espace à deux
dimensions fini l'espace à deux
dimensions fini le plus simple auquel je
puisse penser c'est une sphère
donc si vous posez en chaque point de
votre plan une petite sphère vous
obtenez un espace qui est le plan fois
la sphère deux dimensions a fini deux
dimensions fini alors j'ai choisi la
sphère mais ce n'était pas le seul choix
possible j'aurais pu par exemple prendre
le tort le tort vous savez c'est une
surface en forme de boues et 6 ans
chaque point de mon plan je pose un
petit hors j'obtiens un nouvel espace
qui est le plan fois le tort c'est aussi
un espace
dimensions dont deux fini mais qui est
différent de celui que j'avais avant
alors passons maintenant au cas de la
théorie des cordes je vous ai dit pour
faire ma théorie des cordes il faut dix
dimensions une dimension de temps et
neuf dimensions des espaces sur ces neuf
dimensions des espaces on va en prendre
trois qui vont être infinie c'est les
dimensions habituel et on en veut si ce
qu'ils soient finis donc pour
représenter sa on veut prendre notre
espace tridimensionnel habituel et en
chaque point l'espace on veut poser un
petit espace à six dimensions fini alors
les gens qui font de la théorie des
cordes ont regardé quels étaient les
espaces qui pouvait convenir et sont
rendus compte que les espaces qui
marchait correspondait à ce qu'on
appelle en mathématiques les espaces de
cala by you du nom des deux
mathématiciens qui ont travaillé dessus
alors un espace de cas la bio c'est
assez difficile à se représenter puisque
ça si dimension mais on peut essayer de
le représenter en le projetant en deux
ou trois dimensions et donc ça donne des
choses comme ça voyez c'est assez joli
le problème c'est que de même que tout à
l'heure je pouvais m'amuser à choisir
une sphère où un tort comme espace à
deux dimensions finie et bien là j'ai le
choix entre plaint d' espace deux cas la
bio à ses dimensions et c'est très
important de savoir lequel je vais
choisir pour faire la théorie des cordes
puisque je vous ai dit les cordes
elle vibre et donc elles vont vibrer
dans les dimensions de l'espace deux cas
la bio et la manière dont les cordes
vibre détermine les propriétés des
particules qu'on va trouver dans la
théorie ça veut dire que si moi je
commence à faire de la théorie des
cordes en choisissant un espace de
calvillo et que mon voisin il fait de la
théorie des cordes et qu'il en prend un
autre on va fabriquer deux théories
ayant des propriétés physiques
différentes ayant des particules
différentes et donc il ya autant de
théorie des cordes possible que de
manière de choisir l'espace deux cas la
bio
le problème c'est que entre le choix de
l'espace de calvillo
et puis les autres choix qu'il faut
faire quand on fabrique une théorie des
cordes
c'est ce qu'on appelle le problème du
choix du vide on se rend compte qu'on
peut fabriquer peut-être jusqu'à 10
puissance sans théorie des cordes
différentes
pour les critiques de la théorie des
cordes cette abondance de choix ça rend
la théorie complètement inutilisable si
vous avez 10 puissance en version de
votre théorie ça veut dire que chaque
fois vous essayez de faire une
prédiction expérimental vous avez 10
puissance en prédiction expérimental et
donc dans ces conditions comment on peut
tester la théorie si demain quelqu'un à
se pointe avec un résultat expérimental
nouveau vous allez toujours trouvé une
tetra chier de théorie des cordes qui
sont capables d'expliquer ce résultat
expérimental et donc même pour les plus
virulents critiques du coup la théorie
des cordes est pas une science puisqu'on
peut pas l'attesté expérimentalement
alors les partisans de la théorie des
cordes ils ont réussi à retourner
l'argument à leur avantage avec l'idée
du multivers le multivers ça consiste à
supposer qu'en fait il existerait une
multitude d'univers comme le nôtre qui
seraient déconnectés les uns des autres
et qui seraient potentiellement régi par
des lois physiques différentes et donc
les partisans de la théorie des cordes
disent ça se trouve il existe autant
d'univers que deux variantes possibles
de la théorie des cordes
chacun de ces univers obéit à une
théorie des cordes construite par
exemple avec un espace de cas la vidéo
différents et donc qui déboucherait sur
des lois physiques différentes
et puis nous eh ben on vit simplement
dans un de ces univers alors quand même
tout n'est pas perdu pour tester la
théorie des cordes parce qu'il ya quand
même un ingrédient de la théorie des
cordes qu'on peut espérer vérifier
expérimentalement
c'est ce qu'on appelle la supersymétrie
la supersymétrie j'en ai pas encore
parlé mais c'est un ingrédient essentiel
de la théorie des cordes
c'est une symétrie qui suppose qu'il y
aurait en fait deux fois plus de types
de particules que ce qu'on croyait avant
si on regarde aujourd'hui dans le modèle
standard de la physique des particules
et qu'on compte absolument toutes les
particules les quark les électrons les
neutrinos etc et toutes leurs
antiparticules on trouve qu'il ya 61
type de particule différente et bien la
supersymétrie elle suppose que il en
existerait en fait deux fois plus parce
que chacune de ces particules aurait une
sorte de double ce qu'on appelle le
super partenaire et donc pour les nommer
on s'amuse à rajouter un petit s de vent
donc le super partenaire du quark ces
hausses quark le super partenaire de
l'électron c'est le selectron etc
aujourd'hui on n'a jamais vu
une seule de ces soixante et une
particule supplémentaires les super
partenaire mais les spécialistes de la
supersymétrie pense que normalement ou
lhc dans le collisionneur du cern
on commence à atteindre des énergies où
on devrait voir ces particules si elle
existe si dans les prochains ron du lhc
qui vont avoir lieu dans les prochaines
années on ne voit aucune de ces
particules supersymétriques ça peut
signifier que la supersymétrie n'existe
pas et donc ça ça serait un sérieux
problème pour la théorie des cordes si
finalement la théorie des cordes vais
finir par être démentis
expérimentalement bon ça serait quand
même pas la fin des haricots
c'est vrai que c'est jusqu'aujourd'hui
il approche qui a été le plus étudié
mais c'est pas la seule qui existe pour
essayer de fabriquer une théorie de la
gravité quantique et notamment il existe
une autre approche que j'ai déjà
mentionné qui s'appelle la gravité
quantique à boucles pour comprendre en
quoi la gravité quantique à boucles
diffère de la théorie des cordes
il faut se rappeler que le point de
départ de tout ça c'est que la
quantification perturbe hâtive de la
relativité générale donne des infinis et
le chemin qu'ont choisi les gens qui
font de la gravité quantique à boucles
c'est de dire si la quantification
perturbe hâtive ne marche pas eh ben il
faut faire de la quantification non
perturbe hâtives
le problème c'est que faire de la
quantification non perturbe hâtive c'est
beaucoup plus difficile
ça oblige notamment à utiliser des
objets mathématiques qui sont beaucoup
plus complexes et donc c'est en quelque
sorte le chemin difficile
le gros avantage c'est que la gravité
quantique à boucles elle n'a pas besoin
de faire des hypothèses supplémentaires
sur des choses qu'on n'a jamais vus par
exemple n'a pas besoin de supposer que
le monde ait fait de petites cordes
elle n'a pas besoin de supposer qu'il ya
la supersymétrie elle n'a pas non plus
besoin de supposées qui a des dimensions
supplémentaires
mais bon tout ça je vous raconterai une
prochaine fois merci d'avoir suivi cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à la partager pour
faire connaître la théorie des cordes au
monde entier vous pouvez vous abonner à
la chaîne vous pouvez me retrouver sur
mon blog qui s'appelle science étonnante
et vous pouvez également nous suivre sur
facebook et sur twitter
si vous les avez pas déjà vu bien sûr
invite à aller voir mes vidéos
précédentes à bientôt